so you think a lot of times in
relationships people could be spending
too much time together absolutely
nowadays for sure they live in the same
house they literally spent all day
together and when we figured this out
for our relationship it was still like 2
or 3 years in we actively just like
created a ton of space we worked on
opposite sides of the house I came off
the meetings that she was on and so like
at the end of the day we go for a walk
45 minutes I take out my phone she takes
out her phone we go through our
calendars and we just literally download
like how was your day how was my day
like what are the things that we're
working on and moving forward and that's
how we kind of like resync up and then
after that we just kind of husband and
wife for the the rest of the day